GET TO IT.
TIME FOR OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
I'VE BEEN WARNING FOR WEEKS
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED MIGRANTS, THEY HAVE
BEEN MARCHING TOWARDS AMERICA.
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
PEOPLE, I'VE BEEN SAYING, I
BELIEVE ARE COMING HERE IN
SEARCH OF A BETTER LIFE.
MORE OPPORTUNITY.
A LAND OF OPPORTUNITY.
FREEDOM.
BUT HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
THESE INDIVIDUALS, THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN VETTED.
NO BACKGROUND CHECKS, NO
CRIMINAL HISTORY CHECKS, NO
PROOF OF EMPLOYMENT, NO FAMILY
TIES TO THE U.S., NO
COMPREHENSION, IN SOME CASES, OF
WHAT THE LAWS OF AMERICA ARE.
NO CASE FOR ASYLUM.
MANY HAVE NO PAPERWORK
WHATSOEVER.
BUT THEY ARE DEMANDING ENTRY
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
TONIGHT, THE FIRST MIGRANTS HAVE
NOW REACHED OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
A GROUP OF AROUND 80 MIGRANTS
THAT SPLIT OFF FROM THE MUCH
LARGER GROUP.
THEY CLAIMED WIDESPREAD
HARASSMENT, MISTREATMENT AT THE
HANDS OF THEIR FELLOW MIGRANTS,
AND ABLE TO FAST-TRACK THEIR
JOURNEY TO THE UNITED STATES.
ACCORDING TO THE AP, ANOTHER
GROUP OF SEVERAL HUNDRED
MIGRANTS WILL ARRIVE THE NEXT
FEW DAYS.
SOME HAVE TRIED TO SCALE THE
U.S. BORDER FENCE.
LOOK AT THESE VIDEOS.
TIJUANA.
OTHERS CRAWLED THROUGH OPENINGS
FORCED TO CRAWL BACK BECAUSE
U.S. BORDER CONTROL AGENTS
RESPONDED AND THEY ARE ABOUT TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD FIRST
IMPRESSION.
THIS IS JUST A SMALL PART OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY COMING.
A CLEAR WARNING OF A LOOMING
CRISIS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS FROM
MEXICAN OFFICIALS WHO AS MANY AS
10,000 MIGRANTS ARE JUST DAYS
AWAY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IS WARNING AND THEY
HAVE PUT OUT STATEMENTS THAT
OVER 270 SUSPECTED CRIMINALS,
GANG MEMBERS, DRUG TRAFFICKERS
HAVE BEEN BLENDING IN WITH WHAT
IS MOSTLY A MALE CARAVAN.
IMMIGRANTS DEPORTED FROM THE
U.S., THEY ARE ALSO DETACHED
FROM THE GROUPS.
OVER 700     700 TROOPS HAVE BEE
OVER 700     700 TROOPS HAVE BEN
CONSTRUCTING OTHER BARRIERS TO
PREVENT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
PROTECTING OUR SOVEREIGNTY, OR
RULE OF LAW.
WE ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLI
REPUBLIC.
WEEKS AGO, WE WITNESSED THE
BREAKING DOWN OF THAT FENCE AND
SOUTHERN MEXICO CRASHING THE
GATE INTO THAT COUNTRY.
THIS IS A SERIOUS SITUATION AND
AN IMPORTANT REMINDER OF WHY
STRONG BORDERS THE RULE OF LAW,
THE WALL IS SO IMPORTANT.
IF THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED, THAT HAD BEEN
COMPLETED WITH THE BIG DOOR IN
IT, AS HE SAID, THE SITUATION
WOULD BE MITIGATED.
IT WOULD BE CONTROLLED.
AS A MATTER OF FACT IT WOULD NOT
EVEN BE A POSSIBILITY OF SOME
KIND OF CONFRONTATION.
AMERICA NEEDS IMMIGRANTS.
BUT WE HAVE TO VET ANYONE,
EVERYONE COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY, WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER, OTHER
BAD PEOPLE, EVEN IF THEY ARE
MIXING IN WITH GOOD PEOPLE, FROM
ENTERING THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE VERY REASON WHY
DEMOCRATS FEW SHORT YEARS AGO
SUPPORTED THE ENFORCEMENT OF OUR
BORDER LAWS AND OUR BORDER.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> I VOTED NUMEROUS TIMES WHEN I
WAS A SENATOR TO SPEND MONEY TO
BUILD A BARRIER TO TRY TO
PREVENT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM
COMING IN.
I DO THINK YOU HAVE TO CONTROL
YOUR BORDERS.
VEHICLE PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT OUR
PERMISSION ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND SHOULD NOT BE TREATED THE
SAME AS PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE
U.S. LEGALLY.
THE U.S. PEOPLE WILL NEVER
ACCEPT IMMIGRATION REFORM UNLESS
THEY TRULY BELIEVE THE
GOVERNMENT IS COMMITTED TO
ENDING FUTURE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> THOSE WHO DISRESPECT THE RULE
OF LAW AND BECAUSE WE LIVE IN AN
AGE WHERE TERRORISTS ARE
CHALLENGING OUR BORDERS, WE
CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO POUR INTO
THE U.S. UNDETECTED,
UNDOCUMENTED, AND UNCHECKED.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, NOW THEY
ARE SINGING A MUCH DIFFERENT
TUNE.
THEY SOUNDED LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
THE PARTY HAS MOVED SO FAR
RADICAL LEFT THAT VIRTUALLY NO
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTS BORDER
ENFORCEMENT.
WITH THE CARAVAN MARCHING NORTH,
THE LEFT IS DOING ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING TO PLAY THIS
SITUATION DOWN.
IT COULD GET SERIOUS.
IMAGINE, FOR A SECOND, THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE -- NOT JUST 80, AT THE
BORDER, WHAT HAPPENS THEN?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN WE ARE SENDING 15,000
TROOPS TO THE BORDER FOR A
POLITICAL STUNT?
THAT'S A WARNING SIGN.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CONSIDERING GREAT STRATEGY TO
BRING OUT HIS BASE?
THIS STUPID CARAVAN CONSPIRACY
WHICH HASN'T BEEN TALKED ABOUT
SINCE ELECTION DAY.
>> ESSENTIALLY USING THEM AS
PROPS.
>> IT SEEMS WE'VE GOT THE ALL
CLEAR.
THE EMERGENCY IS OVER.
THE SOLUTION OF THE CARAVAN
INVASION ALL ALONG, IT WASN'T
THE TROOPS, IT WASN'T THE WALL,
IT WAS GETTING PAST THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
>> I JUST REMEMBER WHEN I WOULD
LOOK UP EVERY NIGHT IT WAS, "THE
CARAVAN IS COMING!
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE YOUR JOB!
THEY ARE GOING TO BE DOING ALL
THIS."
NOW YOU DON'T HEAR ANYTHING.
PEOPLE BOUGHT IT.
"OH, MY GOSH, WE SHOULD BE
PUTTING A BARBED WIRE."
>> SOME PEOPLE DIDN'T.
>> Sean: UNLIKE CNN, MSNBC,
THEIR COHORTS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRACK
WHAT IS A VERY SERIOUS
SITUATION.
ALSO FOLLOWING SOME HORRIFIC
NEWS OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
WILDFIRES RIPPING THROUGH AREAS
IN BOTH NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATEWIDE DEATH TOLL IS UP
NOW TOWARDS 51.
THOUSANDS OF BUILDINGS, HOMES,
OTHER STRUCTURES DESTROYED.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DAMAGES.
AND AN ENTIRE TOWN WAS EVEN
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
THE DEVASTATION WAS SHOCKING.
TONIGHT MANY ARE LOOKING FOR
ANSWERS, MAKING A SERIOUS CASE.
COULD THIS FIRE HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED?
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
EDITORIAL BOARD TONIGHT,
FEDERAL, STATE, ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS HAVE LEFT THE
DROUGHT IMPACTED FOREST
INVULNERABLE TO THESE FIRES.
THAT'S NEARLY 130 MILLION TREES
THAT ARE DEAD.
THAT HAVE DIED IN THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS ALONE, THE GOVERNMENT HAS
PREVENTED THEM FROM BEING
CLEARED.
FOR EXAMPLE, "THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT, THE ENVIRONMENT OF
POLICY HAVE HAMPERED TREE
CLEARING, CONTROLLED BURNS,
TIMBER SALES ON FEDERAL LAND."
THE ARTICLE GOES ON.
"CALIFORNIA ALSO RESTRICTS
TIMBER HARVESTING AND REQUIRES
MYRIAD PERMITS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT STATEMENTS TO PRUNE
OVERGROWN FORESTS."
IN CALIFORNIA, TO "BURN LEAVES,
TREE LIMBS, LAND OWNERS MUST
OBTAIN AIR QUALITY PERMITS."
THESE PERMITS ARE EXTREMELY
RESTRICTIVE, CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
PRODUCE, CONTROLLED MAINTENANCE
IN CALIFORNIA'S FOREST, WE GET
THESE FORESTS -- WHEN THESE
FIRES ARE PUT OUT COME OF THIS
HAS TO BE A TOP PRIORITY.
WE CANNOT PUT PEOPLES' LIVES IN
THESE FIRES CAUSE MORE FAR WORSE
AT
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE THAN A
TIMBER EXCAVATION.
IT SHOULDN'T TAKE ANOTHER FIRE
FOR LAWS TO BE ADJUSTED AND ALL
THE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA NOW IN
THESE AREAS HAVE THEIR LIVES AT
RISK.
BY THE WAY, OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH
ALL OF THEM.
ALL IMPACTED BY THIS HORRIFIC
CRISIS.
LOOK AT THAT.
IT IS OUT OF CONTROL.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRACK THEIR
STORY.
BUT FIRST, WE DO TURN TO
FLORIDA.
THE ELECTION CATASTROPHE THAT IS
ONGOING.
TONIGHT, THE STATEWIDE RECOUNT
CONTINUES WITH TOMORROW'S
DEADLINE LOOMING.
BOTH REPUBLICANS, RON DeSANTIS
DeSANTIS, RICK SCOTT LOOK
POISED FOR VICTORY.
THERE ARE SO MANY QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING THE SKETCHY ACTIONS
OF BROWARD COUNTY AND ITS
SUPERVISOR OF ELECTIONS BRENDA
SNIPES.
SHE SOMEHOW MANAGED TO MAGICALLY
FIND -- OH, I FOUND IT!
75,000 PURPORTEDLY UNCOUNTED
BALLOTS DAYS AND DAYS AFTER
ELECTION NIGHT.
BY THE WAY, ALL IN VIOLATION OF
STATE LAW AND THE STATE
CONSTITUTION.
SNIPES CONTINUED TO REPORT THESE
BALLADS IN THE WEEK FOLLOWING
THE ELECTION.
AFTER DAYS, SHE WOULDN'T TELL
ANYBODY WHERE THESE BALLOTS WERE
COMING FROM.
TONIGHT, WE STILL HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT HAPPENED AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE'S CALLING
FOR HER TO BE FIRED.
BUT AS THE RECOUNT ROLLS ON,
SNIPES DID HAVE TIME TO GO ON
CNN AND DEFEND HERSELF.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN CITED,
MS. SNIPES, AS A PROBLEM IN THIS
PROCESS, THAT YOU ARE NOT DOING
THE JOB A TRANSPARENCY, NOT
DOING IT THAT GIVES CONFIDENCE
IN THE OVERALL PROCESS.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE
OPINIONS THAT PEOPLE WHO PUT
FORWARD -- THEY ARE ALL THERE
FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
BUT I LIKE TO CALL TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT THIS MIDTERM
ELECTION, IN ADDITION TO RUNNING
VERY SMOOTHLY, WAS ONE OF THE
MOST HIGHLY PARTICIPATED MIDTERM
ELECTIONS PROBABLY THAT WE'VE
HAD IN 20 YEARS OR MORE.
THERE IS A LOT THAT GOES ON
BEHIND THE SCENES TO MAKE AN
ELECTION POSSIBLE, TO MAKE IT
EFFICIENT, AND TO MAKE IT
SOMETHING THAT VOTERS WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN.
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE DOING THAT.
>> Sean: GIVEN A POOR TRACK
RECORD AS WE HAVE DETAILS EVERY
NIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM WITH
DEADLINES, MAYBE SHE NEEDS TO BE
DOING HER JOB, COUNTING THE
VOTES INSTEAD OF GOING ON
INTERVIEWS.
TONIGHT, FLORIDA IS NOT THE ONLY
STATE FACING INSANE ELECTION
DRAMA.
IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA,
DEMOCRATS ARE REFUSING TO
CONCEDE THAT GOVERNOR'S RACE.
THAT'S BETWEEN STACY ABRAMS AND
REPUBLICAN BRIAN CAMP, DESPITE
NO PATH TO VICTORY FOR ABRAMS.
BY THE WAY, THEY ARE NOT
STOPPING THERE.
FAR LEFT OHIO SENATOR SHERROD
BROWN, HE IS RAMPING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, AND ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF STEALING THE
ELECTION.
>> IF STACY ABRAMS DOESN'T WIN
IN GEORGIA, THEY STOLE IT.
IT'S CLEAR.
I SAY THAT PUBLICLY.
THEY CAN'T WIN ELECTIONS BECAUSE
THERE'S WAY MORE OF US THAN
THERE ARE THEM.
THEY WIN ELECTIONS BY
REDISTRICTING AND VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
IN ALL THE WAYS THEY TRY TO
SCARE PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR, HOW TO MAKE IT
HARD FOR PEOPLE IN, ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE THERE
ARE MORE LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
HE WENT
>> Sean: BEYOND SAD,
PREDICTABLE WITH SOME PEOPLE
STARING RACIAL
COMING STARING RACIAL
TENSIONS, REDISTRICTING WOULD
HAVE ZERO IMPACT OR EFFECT ON
THE STATEWIDE RACE!
BUT OF COURSE, THIS IS NOTHING
NEW FROM THIS CROP OF RADICAL
DEMOCRATS.
THERE SEEMED TO BE NO MODERATES
LEFT IN THE PARTY.
THEY ARE LITERALLY CHEERING FOR
ROBERT MUELLER.
PLEASE, FIND SOMETHING,
ANYTHING!
WE CAN'T DO IT ON OUR OWN.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS FROM THAT
WITCH HUNT.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS LEGAL
TEAM ARE ON THE VERGE OF MAKING
A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN ANSWERS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR THAT
DEVELOPMENT FOLLOWS THE LATEST
ON FROM SENATOR JEFF SNELL FLAKE
WHO EXPOSED HIMSELF AS NOT A
CONSERVATIVE.
HE'S STILL PROTECTING MOTHER TO
THE FLOOR.
PRESIDENT SAID RECENTLY HE HAS
NO PLANS TO DO ANYTHING WITH
MUELLER AND FLAKE IS THREATENING
THE PRESIDENT, ALL HIS
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES SAYING HE
WILL OPPOSE ALL THE PRESIDENTS
JUDICIAL NOMINEES UNTIL HE GETS
HIS WAY AND THE SENATE VOTES ON
THAT LEGISLATIONS THAT SOME
STOMACH PROTECTS MUELLER FROM
BEING FIRED BY THE PRESIDENT
WHICH ISN'T HAPPENING FOR
BLOCKING CONSERVATIVE JUDGES,
BREAKING A PROMISE TO THE PEOPLE
YOU MADE A PROMISE TO IN
ARIZONA?
SENATOR FLAKE SHOULD BE ASHAMED.
THE ARMCHAIR CAUSE ADDITIONAL
SCHOLARS ON LEFT-WING MAINSTREAM
SO-CALLED MEDIA NETWORKS AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
THEY WERE ALL WRONG.
THE ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL, AS
WE ALL TOLD YOU ON THIS PROGRAM
AT WHITAKER, HE DID RECEIVE THE
FULL BACKING OF THE DEPARTMENT F
JUSTICE.
THE DOJ RELEASING A 20 PAGE MEMO
TELLING YOU EXACTLY THE THINGS
WE TOLD YOU, THAT WHITAKER IS
UNQUESTIONABLY AUTHORIZED TO
LEAD THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THEY CITED THE SAME LAW, IN
1998 LAW THAT
THE APPOINTMENT CLAUSE OF THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION ADDING THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN "COUNTLESS
SIMILAR PRESIDENTIAL ORDERS
DATING BACK OVER 200 YEARS."
FINALLY TONIGHT, WE WILL END
WITH ONE VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
IT'S CALLED DUE PROCESS.
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING ALL DURING
THE KAVANAUGH HEARINGS, A
FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLE IN A FAIR
AND JUST SOCIETY, IT HAS SERVED
THIS COUNTRY SO WELL, A PILLAR.
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU REMEMBER
DURING KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS, WE DEFENDED THIS
PRINCIPLE FROM BASELESS ATTACKS
AND IRRESPONSIBLE ACCUSATIONS BY
INDIVIDUALS, SOME ON THE LEFT,
SOME FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
OF COURSE, WE HAVE THAT FAME
SEEKING ATTORNEY MICHAEL
AVENATTI WHO IS ONE OF THOSE
IRRESPONSIBLE ACTORS.
HE BROUGHT FORTH CLAIMS FROM A
CLIENT WHO ACCUSED KAVANAUGH OF
GANG RAPE ON AN ALMOST WEEKEND
BASIS AND DRUGGING YOUNG TEENAGE
GIRLS, BOYS LINING UP IN THE
HALL, AND ONE BY ONE "WAITING
THEIR TURN TO RAPE THESE YOUNG
WOMEN."
NO EVIDENCE, THE STORY
EVENTUALLY CHANGED.
AVENATTI DEMANDED HIS CLIENT AND
ALL OTHERS WHO HAD MADE
ACCUSATIONS THAT THEY SHOULD ALL
BE BELIEVED.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THIS.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT WAS SMART,
IF HE WASN'T SO ARROGANT, HE
WOULD SEE THE WRITING ON THE
WALL, AND HE WOULD PULL THIS
NOMINATION IMMEDIATELY.
IF YOU MAKE ACCUSATION OR
ALLEGATION OF WHETHER OR NOT YOU
STAY OR GO, MICHAEL EMMA
WHAT DOES IT SAY FOR THE FUTURE?
>> THAT'S A VERY GOOD POINT,
CHRIS, BUT WE ARE BEYOND THAT
RELATING TO THE LIE DETECTOR
TEST AND PASSED, WHICH OF COURSE
IS NOT ADMISSIBLE IN A COURT OF
LAW.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT A MERE
ACCUSATION OR ALLEGATION.
HERE IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT POINT.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE
ADJUDICATED IN ONE DAY OR EVEN
TWO DAYS.
>> Sean: WE LEARNED TONIGHT
THAT MICHAEL AVENATTI HAS BEEN
ARRESTED.
TAKEN INTO CUSTODY BY THE
L.A.P.D.
HE'S BEEN CHARGED WITH A SERIOUS
CHARGE, THAT IS FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
HE'S PROCLAIMING HIS INNOCENCE.
AND I WILL BE CONSISTENT ON THE
ISSUES OF DUE PROCESS AND THE
RESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
BUT ONE CAN ONLY WONDER IF NOW
MAYBE MICHAEL AVENATTI WOULD
APPLY THE SAME STANDARD TO
HIMSELF THAT HE HAD APPLIED TO
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
OR MAYBE TONIGHT THAT HE WOULD
PREFER THE COUNTRY GIVE HIM DUE
PROCESS.
AND THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
OR WILL YOU LOCK YOURSELF UP AND
JUST THROW AWAY THE KEY?
I BELIEVE HE DESERVES ASSUMPTION